[Music]
what do you mean by drier though
shorter
not dry oh yeah yeah would you want each
of them to have their own kind of rhythm
or in my previous video where i was
learning about synthesizers i showed
footage of hanging out with andrew huang
and experimenting with his modular
synthesizers what if we let's connect
there was a particular moment that i
really liked so i ended up capturing it
onto a recording device
oh yeah
[Music]
i have it slowed down 60
and i'm going to take it
maybe four beats at a time
close
not quite but close here's what it looks
like in written form
and this is what it sounds like when i
tried to play it on the keyboard
[Music]
never mind after a quick analysis i
determined the falling pitches as the
predominant pitches being used
[Music]
which i'd like to simplify into these
groupings
i hear the track in these layers
first of all this bit
this
this figure which is almost like a
motive
[Music]
and the following on the upper end
there are a lot of repeated notes as you
can hear
and the overall rhythm has a lot of
random syncopation and an irregular
pulse but it's actually rather
consistent in its chance quality
[Music]
now that i've understood it a bit more i
figured i would try improvising over it
while using it as a backing track
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's it for this video i'll turn it
over to you all now what would you do
with this track
[Music]
you